aquí tenemos algunos problemas acerca de
graficar puntos y de representar
visualmente una función empezamos con
este problema que no escribía el
enunciado pero nos pide determinar las
coordenadas de cada uno de estos cinco
puntos muy bien entonces debemos
determinar la coordenada en x que es que
tan a la izquierda o derecha está del
origen el punto y tenemos que determinar
la coordenada en que es que tan arriba o
qué tan abajo está del origen vamos a
empezar con el punto a entonces el punto
y el punto a pues está 1 2 3 4 5 6
unidades a la izquierda está aquí en el
-6 entonces su coordenada en x sería
menos seis muy bien y su coordenada
hintze sería que tan alto está tenemos
que ir acá para ver qué tan alto está
está a cuatro unidades arriba y por lo
tanto su coordenada en es 4 entonces
tiene coordenadas menos 6,4 muy bien
vamos al punto b lo voy a poner en color
morado el punto de estas siete unidades
a la derecha
siete unidades a la derecha entonces b
es igual a 7,6 unidades arriba entonces
sus coordenadas serían 7,6 ok ahora
vamos al punto c el punto c está acá
dice aquí menos 8 entonces está 8
unidades a la izquierda punto se tiene
coordenada x igual a menos 8 y está dos
unidades abajo está en menos 2 en ya
igual a menos 2 entonces su coordenada
yesería menos 2 muy bien ahora vamos a
pasar al punto de el punto de lo voy a
poner con este color azul claro entonces
el punto de esta cuatro unidades a la
derecha cuatro unidades a la derecha
entonces de ese ya igual bueno las
coordenadas desde serían cuatro y esta 7
unidades hacia abajo aquí está el menos
siete entonces sería 4 -7 muy bien
estos problemas están muy tranquilitos
verdad ya nada más nos falta un punto
vamos al punto
punto es este de acá su coordenada n x 5
entonces aquí sería 5,8 observa no está
ni arriba ni abajo del eje x entonces
pues no está ni arriba ni abajo del
origen y por tanto su coordenada es cero
podemos pensar que está sobre esta línea
sale entonces sería 5,0 muy bien aquí ya
tenemos las coordenadas de los puntos
vamos al siguiente problema problema 5
determina si cada relación de las que
nos dan en estos incisos es una función
ok la idea clave de este problema es que
para que una relación sea una función
necesitamos que cada valor de x lo mande
únicamente a un valor en ye a qué me
refiero con esto déjame darte un ejemplo
de algo que no es una función por
ejemplo si tuviéramos que fx es igual a
5 si x es igual a 1 y que es igual a 6
si x es igual a 1
entonces esto de aquí trae problemas
porque si me piden determinar cuánto es
f1 yo no sabría decirlo no sé si es 5 o
si es 6 entonces esto no puede definir
una función está asignando más de un
valor a un mismo valor de x vamos a ver
qué sucede con estos incisos vamos al
inciso a entonces en el inciso a dice el
1 lo mandamos al 7 ok no hay problema el
2 lo mandamos al 7 aquí tampoco hay
problema porque son dos valores
distintos x que caen en un mismo valor
de iu y eso no es problemático déjame
ponerlo así mira nos están diciendo que
fx es igual
es igual a 7 si x es igual a 1 o 2 y
esto no tiene ningún problema antes si
nos pedían determinar efe 1 entonces no
podíamos darlo porque no sabíamos si era
5 o 6 pero ahora no hay problema efe de
uno claramente 7 efe de 2 claramente
también es 7 bueno entonces hasta
ahorita vamos bien nos dicen que el 13
al 8 el 4 se va al 8 entonces podemos
poner aquí
fx es igual a 8 si x es igual a 3 o 4 y
finalmente nos dicen que f de 569
entonces fx es 9 si x es igual a 5 y
listo no tuvimos ningún problema no
tuvimos que asignar más de un valor de g
para un valor de x y por lo tanto esta
de acá si es función el inciso a si
determina una función
vamos al inciso b en el inciso b nos
dicen que el punto uno va al 1 y nos
dicen que el punto uno va al menos uno
si estoy aquí ya es un problema verdad
nos están diciendo que fx es igual
1 si x es igual a 1 pero que es igual a
menos 1 si x es igual a 1 es exactamente
el mismo problema que acá arriba si nos
piden determinar f1 no podemos decir
quién es y por lo tanto el inciso b no
determina una función muy bien entonces
déjame pasar aquí abajo a los siguientes
problemas vamos con este de acá que
tiene una gráfica ver que parece una
nube y el problema dice describe la
regla de la función para cada gráfica
muy bien entonces queremos determinar la
regla de la función pero aquí parece que
pasan dos cosas verdad una cuando f es
mayor que cero y otra cuando f es menor
que cero bueno vamos a ponerle mayor o
igual que cero y menor que cero entonces
que nos quedaría pues nuestra función
efe vamos a empezar pensando la así como
te dije que va a ser cierta cosa para
los x que son mayores o iguales que cero
va a ser otra cosa para las equis que
son menores que 0 vale ok entonces si x
es mayor o igual que 0 que sucede pues
el 2 lo manda al 1
el 4 lo manda al 2 el 6 lo manda al 3 al
parecer siempre divide entre dos el
número entonces aquí le vamos a poner un
medio por equis vale entonces eso es si
x es mayor o igual que 0
vamos con x menor que cero y ahorita
vemos si las podemos juntar si x es
menor que cero qué pasa pues el menos 2
lo manda al 1 en menos 4 lo manda al 2
el menos 6 lo manda al 3 entonces como
que otra vez divide a la mitad pero
además le cambia el signo entonces aquí
tendríamos menos un medio por x ahora
estoy aquí ya es una respuesta
totalmente válida pero si queremos
vernos un poquito más sofisticados
podemos escribirla pues de una manera un
poco más limpia utilizando el valor
absoluto a qué me refiero con esto bueno
pues me refiero a que podemos escribir
fx así podemos escribir a efe x como un
medio del valor absoluto de x y poner
este valor absoluto ya contempla a ambas
opciones observa si x es mayor o igual
que 0
el valor absoluto de x es simplemente
equis pero si x es menor que cero el
valor absoluto de x es menos x entonces
con esto podemos abreviar un poco la
función y bueno si si funciona si le
pones x igual a menos 2 a menos 2
debería dar 1 y aquí en efecto menos 2
en valor absoluto es 2 y entre 2da
muy bien vamos con el último problema
este último problema es el 10 y dice usa
el criterio de la línea vertical para
determinar si cada relación es una
función y esto del criterio de la línea
vertical es básicamente lo que hicimos
aquí arriba
o sea el criterio de la línea vertical
garantiza que para cada valor de x
tenemos solo un valor de g
entonces eso es básicamente lo que
queremos hacer aquí visualmente y de qué
se trata el criterio de la línea
vertical pues simplemente trazamos
líneas verticales aquí en la gráfica así
verticales y el chiste es asegurarnos
que pasen por solo un punto de la
gráfica por aquí y por aquí por acá que
quiere decir que pasen por solo un punto
pues que para cada valor de x le podemos
trazar su línea vertical intersectan
solo un punto y por lo tanto la función
en efecto solo asigna un valor y bueno
entonces si es función entonces por acá
por acá también tenemos un punto en fin
cualquier línea vertical que trazamos va
a interceptar a esta gráfica en
únicamente un punto y por lo tanto por
el criterio de la línea vertical el a si
es función pero qué sucede con el inciso
b en el inciso b si trazamos esta línea
vertical o bueno básicamente cualquiera
tenemos que la línea intersecta a la
gráfica en dos puntos en este de acá y
en este de acá y eso lo que nos dice es
por ejemplo que f de menos tres
efe de menos tres pues puede ser 2.1 2.1
o puede ser menos 2.1 y entonces tenemos
ambigüedad porque estamos asignando le
dos valores a menos tres lo mismo pasa
aquí en el cero también esta línea
vertical cruza dos veces y de hecho en
cualquier lugar que la atrás hemos
tocado dos veces y bueno entonces
básicamente lo que nos está diciendo el
criterio de la línea vertical es que
como la línea vertical toca más de una
vez
aquí tocados pero con que toque más de
una vez entonces eso lo que
dices que la relación ya no es función